Thanksgiving is lit yo yeah it's my
favorite holiday and they were trying to
kill a group of people that they thought
look they thought was me not until they
got that stomach full sucked so much
more if he actually got to see actual
Indians like from India and we're on the
emoji I asked if we got to actual India
from dori Turkey under it no [ __ ] Turkey
give me that chicken oh you write about
it give us that chicken you already have
food down these things Americans can't
cook shipped right turkey dry corn real
chocolate have we as any Native American
food continued past Thanksgiving I mean
their idea of a feast was just a bucket
full of vegetables buffalo burgers a
cornucopia cornucopia with buffalo
burgers Buffalo is Native American
that's some [ __ ] thing and they're using
every part of the Buffalo buffalo wings
buffalo he started there no they did not
start that why did I call buffalo
because it's from Buffalo the city dogs
yes that's why okay but back to the
Native American he's so upset because I
should be bothering me bro I should be
really bothering me look here's here's
the thing Native Americans the cuisine
fell off did it not fell off he
shouldn't even been on I would go so far
as to say maybe they ate that dry ass
Turkey and stuff and they're like get
rid of these [ __ ] III really
literally I really a little bit if I'm
if I may if I may you may okay
I think the food was so bad that the
settlers were like oh they don't even
have a culture okay so they're like they
won't mind if we just take over I would
go so far as to say that Thanksgiving is
actually a British meal Wow Wow let's go
over it mashed potatoes ain't got no
[ __ ] potatoes in a
that's the Irish thing
there was no potatoes here what did they
ask the traditional English breakfast
bangers and mash bang okay what else did
we laughs stuffing definitely British
that's why people are why people put
more bread in something yeah well what
else is that the only thing they got is
corn corn scorn slaps though corn slap
snog refer I don't even think we use the
same corn they call that [ __ ] maize
right it was mad little yeah it was mad
little okay and they called it maize my
point is like if corn is your
contribution to the meal that's rude
because our bodies don't even eat that
[ __ ] bro you read corn you go up more
corn
yo that's probably when he found out he
was not in India Christopher Columbus is
only ate that dry ass blind ass food and
no spice on this [ __ ] yo real talk point
y'all talk about how trash white
people's food is hmm mailer canned food
worse I think it's the same so they
didn't even have alcohol attention are
you paying to food and cuisine and
entertainment that your even got
Oklahoma do it out how amazing
alcohol is and our food is is it now
they're like addicted non-stop they
can't help it the second they got white
people food they were just addicted
well what's fighting for food alcohol
and alcohol math bland it's being warm
at night no they got addicted to being
warm at night bro they never have
blankets only came through I got some
more Indian food okay go knave American
sorry yeah thank you uh deer meat
venison yeah okay yes hey no Rogan
probably likes it though say you better
this how wack venison is deers down the
highway all the time a nobody like yo
let's carve up a burger wasn't it
between a venison and an elk very animal
well yeah they're different animals
that's the difference a beer is more of
like the I think I think most people
would agree yeah you know and alec is a
boss ass animal a deer is would be at
like a pride march yeah I do like Matt
graceful yeah yeah
deer be prancing cute with a little
bunny tail shaking that thing you know
Cottontail bunny
we got a pumpkin pumpkin slaps yo yo I
thought that was why people all that
along with y'all should have let them
live suck son can I can i no logical
soul fooled pumpkins can I be honest
with you so food pumpkin not can I be
honest with you can I be honest with you
that's the white pig is this Punk
yeah I get a lot with you know you
already what color is sugar brown I
really throw french sugars white okay
right sure the Domino one is right maybe
they ain't got Domino back then but I
sure as [ __ ] they kill black people with
the very game they love Domino's sugar
just like that Jesus they take something
Brown and make it white is the Domino
sugar yo okay
well I was trying to make some
correlations but I'm not the Oh pumpkin
is trash without sugar it's trash
without sugar with sugar it's amazing
can I give you another example Seminole
what is this cinnamon yeah trash without
sugar add the sugar unreal on real take
real undo it
when you add cinnamon to the sugar isn't
sugar more of a Native American thing no
they kind of got some [ __ ] fire flame
I can't America's yo maple syrup vanilla
turkey Native American that's pick a
hole in a tree peanut butter Oh relax
real talk how is it George Washington
Carver hasn't had a [ __ ] movie made
after him we got a planter peanut
why don't we got George Washington
Carver our nation you got aunt jemima on
the syrup so we didn't put did we put on
to mama on the syrup we know damn well
aren't you mom I didn't get the [ __ ]
syrup out of the tree we need to land
olakes lady on the gin Jemima syrup bang
no we need a [ __ ] hummingbird or
woodpecker if I give them their credit
yo they didn't invent that you know
drunk dad to be to be sucking off a tree
oh yeah I didn't do it cuz y'all are
busy drinking yeah high alcohol they
need some house it you have to admit
white people have been incredibly
effective given our addiction alcohol
we've been the most effective alcoholics
no I just steal everything Irish people
are yeah but we got our wits we got our
wits together cuz your inhibitions it
down so now you're just all let me just
rob this mom okay give me dad it helped
you and Irish people mad effective at
what I've already even grown potatoes
[ __ ] losers no son how you keep that
[ __ ] like they're like potato famine did
you try put it in the ground
did you try planting the potato that's
like the first thing they teaches an
elementary school but
somehow the potatoes don't come out of
the ground you telling me it was too
sunny
there was a time [ __ ] great brand
where it was too dry and sunny the most
wet place on the [ __ ] earth I don't
believe this potato famine yeah they
would do drunk say what they were too
drunk you drunk to be effective yeah but
that's Irish that's the whitest was the
wood that's why why is it no that's
translucent way nah you don't think that
that Shaun King white Jean King is Irish
yeah yeah bored about the black Irish oh
that's a good point you haven't heard
about them have you haven't
what's that person say what's that a
black president the black Irish the
Spanish Armada they came to uh they came
to Ireland and they made them black
that's the token you see this is an
Irish person would like brown hair so it
really is they just called people around
her that's how white brown hair made you
black Oh Martin attacked me on that that
might be true though yeah I'll look it
up there actually is an interesting
correlation we're like Irish slave
owners that came over would give like
slaves would get the last name of where
they were from or they would get the
name of where they were from yeah sure
so Tyrone Ireland is like one of the
most it's like a wealthy part of Ireland
back in the day that people used to come
over and that's why I like a lot of
black people named Tyrone allegedly oh
so Tyrone is a white name little
cultural appropriation as ours now
[Applause]